votre réaction aux révélations du monde
sur la surveillance du député thierry
solère par la dgse alors qu'il était
encore candidat face à claude guéant
alors ministre de l'intérieur manuel
valls juge cette surveillance
insupportable et vous alors si c'est
vrai si c'est prouvé
parce que évidemment c'est pas des
allégations
enfin on her ne s'appuie pas uniquement
sur des allégations mais si c'est prouvé
sa porte un nom extrêmement précis ça
s'appelle une forfaiture c'est à dire la
trahison par un officier public
quelqu'un qui occupe une fonction
publique de sa fonction les services
secrets les services de sécurité ils
sont pas là pour surveiller l'adversaire
politique du ministre qui est en place
peut-être ça s'est fait dans le passé
mais en tout cas c'est c'est une
atteinte intolérable à l'idée qu'on se
fait d'une fonction et à ce stade les
dénégations de clogher ne vous suffisent
pas puisqu'il assure n'avoir joué aucun
rôle dans cette affaire
mais le grand d'ailleurs au ministre de
la défense de diligenter une enquête
si la phrase que vous me citez est exact
il ne dit pas que ça n'a pas eu lieu
il parle de son rôle à l'huilerie sont
absents et on en l'espèce et il est
franchement comment imaginer que des
démener de cet ordre soit conduite
contre l'adversaire électorale du
ministre sans que le ministre d'une
manière ou d'une autre n'était né tu as
le souhaitez même si c'est souvent des
basses manoeuvres qu'on fait faire
plutôt que on ne les fais moi en tout
cas je trouve que si c'est vrai c'est
encore une fois des histoires d'officine
dans la république d'utilisation de des
services de l'état pour assurer la
sécurité à des fins bassement politiques
si c'est vrai c'est intolérable et c'est
une forfaiture intolérable dites-vous
comme le premier ministre est une
forfaiture ça vous fait jeter hors jeu
pas envie de vous dire que ça vous fait
jeter un nouveau regard sur le le
quinquennat de nicolas sarkozy est ce
que je me trompe
j'ai écrit un livre sur ce qui s'est
passé à cette époque qui s'appelait abus
de pouvoir parce que il me semblait
c'était un titre à plusieurs sens mais
il me semblait qu'il y avait dans la
pratique du pouvoir
je pensais par exemple à des affaires à
la ferme
tapie qui depuis a été jugé par la
justice dans le sens que j'avais analysé
à cette époque je pensais qu'il y avait
là des choses keane qui n'allait pas et
si cette dernière affaire est prouvée
alors on est encore une fois dans ce
domaine de l'abus de pouvoir et là votre
société temps des dieux j'ai pas tout à
fait fini ça accrédite le ca accrédite
le diagnostic que j'ai porté depuis
longtemps puis il ya une deuxième chose
c'est qu'elle est le fond de tout ça
peut dire où ça mène alors je suis un
homme du centre je n'ai jamais pensé que
la droite et la gauche n'existait pas
j'ai dit que ce clivage ne pouvait plus
être le clivage dans lequel on se
reconnaissent mais moi ce que je crois
c'est qu'il y a un projet original du
centre que ça ressemble pas et que ça
n'est pas la même chose va est ce que je
puis vous rappeler une phrase que
j'avais dit il ya longtemps lorsqu'on a
créé l'ump soi disant parti unique de la
droite et du centre
à l'époque les gens disaient mais au
fond on pense tous la même chose et
j'avais dît si on pense tous la même
chose c'est qu'on ne pense plus rien et
l'idée que indifféremment tout le monde
se retrouve sans connaître le projet
parce que ce qu'on entend
ça n'a pas de sens je veux dire ça n'a
pas de profondeur moi ce qui me manque
c'est le projet dans tout ça notre
projet de société
sans aller jusque-là exemple une dizaine
de réforme par exemple il y aurait
consensus web un souci est autre chose
ça c'est une méthode c'est pas du tout
sur les comptes préconise la et donc le
l'absence de fonds l'absence de projet
construit est pour moi une interrogation
leur handicap ou le handicap est une
interrogation
le ce dont j'ai besoin c'est de savoir
où l'on va et par exemple le sentiment
que il n'y aurait que l'économie et que
l'économie financière qu'il faudrait
servir qu'au fond tout le monde serait
obligée d'en passer par là
ce cette petite musique qu'on entend il
suffit de voir les soutiens en parle
toujours de monsieur mac on entend le
procès à la fois de clients ce n'est pas
un procès c'est une interrogation pour
moi ça ne correspond pas à ce que
j'attends d'en savoir ce qu'attendent
des millions de français d'accord donc
nba ce cas est donc le je pense que ce
qui est très important c'est de
construire une vision de l'avenir qu'ils
apportent aux français un peu de raisons
de s'engager quelque chose à quoi on
croirait qu'ils soient qu'ils ne
seraient pas mais financière et qui ne
serait pas uniquement le facteur commun
comparer d'écrire aujourd'hui d'accord
avec avec une on va dire une une
une présentation sommaire de
l'ultralibéral libéralisation du pays
j'attends que nous nous trouvions à
partir de 2017 dans un nouveau cycle
dans une nouvelle ère de la vie
politique française dans laquelle on
réponde de manière différente à toutes
les aspirations des français sur
l'éducation où on a échoué et gravement
a mon avis part par manque de réflexion
sur le fond par exemple
j'attends qu'on rompe clairement avec la
politique actuelle du gouvernement en
matière éducative menée dans 20 cantons
l'arrêt en vendant les collèges en
particulier j'attends une rupture
franche
j'attends que on se trouve avec une
politique qui permette de qu'une
confiance nouvelle phase créer des
contrats de travail alors que c'est à
peu près le contraire de ce qu'on est en
train de faire entendre parler dans une
minute
j'attends que la france est une
proposition européenne différente de ce
que nous avions jusqu'à aujourd'hui on
va en parler tout à l'heure dans le 3e
série d'obtenir ce sont des demandes que
vous vous adressez donc mais ce sont des
demandes que jamais que j'adresse
priorité à tous ceux qui voudraient
avoir la responsabilité
j'espère de porter l'alternance dans le
pays et pour moi c'est le fond de mon
engagement on n'est pas là uniquement
pour des problèmes de personnes n'ont
peur que les personnes ça compte
beaucoup m'ont donné son présidentielle
mais on est là pour changer la réalité
du pays
je pense que françois hollande a
bénéficié d'un crédit qui était aussi
largement du refus de nicolas sarkozy de
la poursuite de son mandat il a
bénéficié d'un crédit
il a gaspillé ce crédit en refusant
d'aller au bout des changements et des
réformes et des pratiques c'est il en
avait la responsabilité
maintenant c'est trop tard et je ne
crois pas qu'il puisse retrouver son
créer une nouvelle fois le gouvernement
est parti avec des intentions et on se
retrouve avec une loi qui est exactement
opposée aux intentions qui avait été
annoncé sur beaucoup de sujets mais sur
ce sujet là en particulier et je trouve
ça terrible pour pour le pour le
jugement que le gouvernement doit porter
sur lui même pourquoi ben c'est très
simple le gouvernement avait dit nous
allons alléger le travail et le rendre
plus souples étant donné que tout le
monde à peu près quelles que soient les
responsabilités et en particulier les
universitaires qui travaillent sur le
travail parce que faut quand même
prendre ce travail là c'est
universitaire 10
il ya deux choses qui pénalise le
travail en france c'est le coût du
travail
d'un côté et c'est de l'autre côté la
rigidité des contrats de travail c'est
pour ça que 80
un bis % ou presque 5 % des contrats
signés sont des contrats en cdd et donc
grosso modo tout le monde avait dit les
prix nobel d'économie jean tirole les
responsables politiques j'en suis avait
dit la bonne direction s'est en effet
allégé assouplir que fait-on on alourdit
on se retrouve au bout du chemin on
alourdit et en régie d'ifi ce changement
de cap est pour le gouvernement a à un
symptôme d'impuissance et de faiblesse
et d'impuissance et de faiblesse en
particulier parce que le gouvernement
vous dites est ce qu'il a répondu à la
jeunesse c'est une blague sur les
bourses c'est cette occasion non mais
parlons de ce sujet finissons avec ce
sujet c'est une blague
ce qu'on appelle les organisations c'est
une organisation qui comporte quelques
quelques milliers de militants et qui
tend à se faire passer pour le porte
parole des autres les jeunes français cl
si si on veut bien partager avec eux un
dialogue en profondeur qu'est-ce qui est
qu'est-ce qui doit crever les yeux mais
à ce qui crève les yeux c'est qu'ils
sont au chômage et que on trouve
infiniment brin de travail chez nous
même quand on est diplômé qu'on en
trouve ailleurs on en trouve davantage
diplômés que pas diplômés mais les les
taux de chômage sont effrayants et la
manière dont on conduit cette chose va
les accentuer parce que si vous croyez
que c'est en alourdissant le céder dès
qu'on favorise le cdi vous vous mettez
le doigt dans l'oeil jusqu'à l'omoplate
alors vous avez désespérant comme penser
et c'est désespérant comme faiblesse
c'est désespérant comme incapacité à
définir un cap et à défendre ce cas
manuel valls il n'est plus droit dans
ses bottes il est un concept beaucoup de
choses aux jeunes bon c'est quelqu'un
que j'estime donc je vais pas me joindre
au groupe de ceux qui l'accablent
même si mon jugement sur cette décision
est extrêmement sévère mais je pense
qu'il doit pas être fier de lui il doit
pas être content c'est pas que c'est pas
la direction qu'ils avaient tracé
ce n'est pas le courage qu'il avait
défini et c'est encore une fois un faux
semblant
quand on pense qu'on prétend défendre
les jeunes en imposant l'immobilisme
dans une situation qui les conduit au
chômage je trouve ça désespérant
nos politiques de lutte contre la
toxicomanie ne marche pas et notamment
contre le cannabis présenté à tort ou à
raison je crois plutôt à tort comme une
drogue douce
mais l'alcool aussi est une drogue et
qui n'est pas douce il suffit de voir
les addictions qui sont créées
deuxièmement je ne crois pas que la
consommation de cannabis soit anodine je
dis pas pour ceux qui fument comme ça
une cigarette de enfin fois le saint des
saints - il y en a qui ont eu une
consommation festive modéré mais
malheureusement je connais des
adolescents qui ont une consommation qui
n'est pas festive et qui est tragique
il ya aussi comme vous savez des
consommations d'alcool chez les
adolescents qui sont pas qu'ils sont
tragiques aussi deuxième chose crois pas
que ça soit anodin je pense que ça a un
effet psychotrope de psychotropes
dangereux troisièmement on nous dit ça
va si on le légalisons va faire baisser
le revenu les trafics et les violences
et on va avoir des cités assainies je
n'en crois rien parce que les le
les ressources tirées de ces trafics
elles seront recherchés ailleurs et dans
des drogues par exemple le crack on sait
bien ça aux états unis ce violent des
drogues plus violent puissant encore et
donc est donc c'est un débat très
difficile mais je ne veux pas en tout
cas qu'on puisse le résumé sous la forme
qu'ils avaient faite par les promoteurs
de cette mesure et moi je ne suis pas
favorable à la légalisation du cannabis
même langue le congrès pour le statu quo
non je je pense que le que le travail de
prévention n'est pas fait et je suis pas
pour le statu quo de ce point de vue là
l'europe 1 souffre de coire elle souffre
d'une espèce d'impuissance elle souffre
d'un désordre intérieur parce que les
règles adoptées par les uns ne sont pas
les mêmes que les règles adoptées par
les autres et notamment en matière
fiscale
c'est à dire que pour moi le combat pour
l'harmonisation fiscale
l'unification de nos règles fiscales en
tout cas dans les pays de même niveau de
développement
c'est un enjeu de première priorité et
l'europe elle souffre d'une deuxième
chose que tout ça illustre si on y
réfléchit bien c'est que on ne sait pas
qui prend les décisions
quand on prend les décisions sur quel
agenda on prend les décisions
quels sont les quels sont les mécanismes
qui permettent de prendre les décisions
personne ne le sait y compris pas vous
mêmes de questions et même nous trois
c'est à dire que nous sommes parmi les
plus amères et hôpitaux en principe non
c'est inquiétant pour tous les citoyens
nous sommes en principe pas remis les
plus avertis qui savait qu'on était en
train de préparer ce texte parmi vous
qu'est ce que c'est ça que je trouve
plus beaucoup plus informés que je ne le
suis parce que c'est ça que les procès
rejette dans l'union européenne
oui ce que pour moi la principale raison
du gouffre qui s'est creusé entre
l'union européenne et ses mécanismes
politiques et les citoyens de tous les
pays européens
c'est le mur qui fait que les citoyens
ne sont informés de rien or il est
impossible aux siècles démocratique que
des décisions majeures pour les sociétés
les citoyens soient prises sans que
personne n'en soit informé est ce que
vous saviez pas et donc c'est cette
question la centrale c'est à dire de la
2de l'ouverture de au moins de
l'information et de l'information
préalable pour que si une décision se
préparent les citoyens puissent
intervenir sur la préparation vous leur
demandez droit vous attendez quoi
finalement aujourd'hui à ben j'attends
que l'europe change du tout au tout
sa pratique le pnr nous manuel valls par
l'instance est l'armé essentielle contre
le terrorisme non c'est une des armes et
il faut prendre toutes les armes
disponibles
il faut adopter c'est le mot que je
cherchais toutes les armes disponibles
et celle là en particulier et je ne
comprends pas alors je sais très bien
les débats qui a autour de tout ça qui
est des gens qui pensent que la
confiscation des données est utilisé
contre les libertés
moi je ne vois pas ce risque ce que je
vois c'est au contraire qu'on favorise
la plus grande atteinte à la liberté qui
est l'insécurité
au débat du secret des affaires et en
même temps on parle de transparence
si l'europe schizophrène oui je mais
nous parlons de transparence fiscale
moi je ne demande pas qu'on soit informé
de la manière dont les marchés se
négocie entre telle entreprise était
notre entreprise
voyez c'est toujours pareil on confond
tourner utilise les mots que haas a fait
un sale mingo un salmigondis un boulbi
boulga dans lequel personne ne reconnaît
ces deux reconnaît nos sens et votre le
sang et schoten je demande que quand on
parle ça veut dire quelque chose et je
demande que on est des règles
compréhensible par tous les citoyens
la règle c'est que la fiscalité doit
s'appliquer à tous les agents
économiques de la même façon dans les
pays européens du même niveau de
développement